the last time we saw rogan you got to
hear this so you were promoting steve
jobs yeah you were on the kelly ripa
show yeah with michael strahan yeah you
wanted to call us i did so you were like
hey i need a landline yes or so i need
somewhere quiet to call what happened
was i had to call at exactly
like 7 45 or whatever it was and and i
was my car there was traffic and so i
got there like a little bit like it was
pushing it and the only
room with the phone that was empty it
was literally like i was looking at two
doors and one was hugh jackman's
dressing room it was michael's straight
head jesse group right and i was like
[ __ ] it i'm going michael strahan on
this one yeah because he's the host and
they got to be nice to you because
you're doing the show i went in there
and uh at first it was empty aside from
two
uh like women who worked for him like
makeup like that yeah
but then uh they very quickly wanted me
the [ __ ] out of them yeah michael walked
in well first someone came in with a
sign that said like you gotta get out of
here and i like waved him off and was
like [ __ ] you like
and then they left for a few minutes and
then the cab came back with like somehow
like a more
firmly written sign that was like
seriously yelling at you do you have to
get at it
yeah exactly he was always capitalized
with exclamation marks and i still waved
him off and i just wouldn't leave you
mean he's changing and they're telling
you to get out and you won't leave no
yeah now he's in his underwear
they genuinely don't want to be at this
room they don't all right this room on
this side of the phone it's not a joke
all right listen to me
uh go see seth rogen i think it was one
of those things where the people at
the kelly and michael's show
were worried that michael would get mad
at them for sticking me in his dressing
room
on the phone with you
so funny we got we got so many emails
about it and then like a bunch of the
guys around here were going you know
what we got to do let's get seth rogen
to go on his whole tour and just call us
from different dresses
i said it was a moment that happened
you can't recreate